la saison touristique est partie sur les
chapeaux de roue depuis son lancement le
week-end de Pâques touristes français
européen ou américain sont de retour en
Touraine 2023 sera une année record on
pose la question à notre invité bonjour
Pascal Brault vous êtes le directeur
donc de du château d'artignies et
président de Touraine hôtel observateurs
privilégié donc de cette saison
touristique qui se dessine qu'en est-il
sur le front des réservations la saison
se présente plutôt bien donc
beaucoup de réservations de clients
d'Amérique du Nord l'Amérique du Sud
aussi on a même moi j'ai vu pas mal de
clients australiens j'étais très très
surpris c'est le retour des étrangers
c'est vraiment le retour des étrangers
excepté peut-être les clients chinois on
sait que c'est voilà c'est toujours un
petit peu compliqué pour eux de
reprendre les voyages mais asiatique
peut si on a quand même si si on a on a
eu des Thaïlandais il y a pas très très
longtemps ici hormis hormis la Chine ça
reprend un petit peu partout c'est une
clientèle pourtant très attendue parce
que Sylviane ils viennent avec des tours
opérateurs des groupes débuts sentiers
des groupes donc pour l'instant on est à
combien à peu près vous savez si
les hôtels enfin où on en est des
réservations à peu près là par rapport à
l'année dernière la plupart des hôtels
ont un petit peu d'avance sur le
réservation donc ça peut être variable
en fonction du type du type de tel et de
la localisation mais
les prévisions sont plutôt bonnes
optimistes aidé par les ponts du mois de
mai j'imagine aussi c'est très bien
cette année là on est effectivement sur
des ponts comme ça on a beaucoup de
Parisiens aussi évidemment puis donc
c'est une très bonne chose est-ce que
les clients réservent toujours autant à
l'avance ou alors la clientèle étrangère
évidemment on va réserver deux mois
trois mois ou plus à l'avance alors que
la tendance avec les clients français
c'est vraiment ce sont vraiment des
réservations de dernière minute les
Parisiens par exemple vont regarder un
petit peu la météo le jeudi pour faire
des réservations sur pour le week-end
donc on a des réservations de dernière
minute et tout ça c'est très on est très
dépendant de la météo évidemment ça
paraît un paramètre un facteur important
bon il y a de la pluie en ce moment il a
fait sec les jours d'avant on s'achemine
vers vers une saison où là dessus il y
aura pas trop de soucis il y a eu les
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites c'était c'était en mars des
images un peu
d'ordre troublé on va dire est-ce que ça
génère un peu les les réservations
c'était un frein pour la clientèle
française évidemment c'est un petit peu
gênant aussi à l'étranger puisqu'il y a
quand même des images qui ont circulé
voilà c'est toujours même si c'est très
localisé les problèmes de de poubelle ou
de manifestations mais la façon dont
s'est traité par certains médias à
l'étranger dans la pression que c'est un
petit peu la guerre civile en France
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit il y a pas
longtemps les amis canadiens m'ont dit
ouh là là ça se passe très mal en France
je leur dis non vous inquiétez pas bon
il y a des endroits où pas la guerre
civile ou c'est calme pour assurer une
bonne saison faut de la main d'oeuf ou
des gens faut des saisonniers de qualité
est-ce qu'il y a un problème toujours de
ce côté-là le recrutement des
saisonnières c'est toujours un petit peu
en tension bien évidemment il reste
encore quelques centaines de postes de
saisonnières recruter pour assurer la
saison mais bon à partir du mois de juin
juin juillet on peut compter aussi sur
des étudiants qui recherchent des jobs
sur sur deux mois donc pas d'inquiétude
de ce côté-là non je pense que ce sera
un petit peu moins compliqué que les
autres les autres années là aussi c'est
très très différent en fonction en
fonction des établissements à Tours
c'est peut-être plus facile dans les
campagnes c'est plus compliqué peut-être
pour recruter et chez vous à Montbazon
au château d'artignies alors comment ça
se passe là moi j'ai pas de problème de
recrutement l'équipe est voilà l'équipe
est pratiquement en place pour la saison
j'ai pas voilà ouais je parle du Château
d'Artigny parce que bientôt un bel
événement va marquer la vie de votre
établissement un concert privé de M le
16 mai 200 privilégier
c'est un concert un concert Alouette
avec nos amis d'alouette évidemment et
donc là bon moi je suis un grand fan de
Mathieu Chedid il a l'habitude de venir
régulièrement en Touraine il s'était
produit sur terre du son en 2014 on l'a
vu il y a pas très longtemps le 30 mars
aussi à Tours un très très beau concert
et là c'est dans un cadre un petit peu
différent donc c'est on peut dire c'est
lui qui a choisi le lieu donc donc on
est ravi et on est très fier alors
régulièrement vous faites des concerts
il y a des il y a vous inviter des
groupes c'est une tendance qui va
s'accentuer au château artigny ainsi un
petit peu dans l'ADN du château quand
même évidemment bon là c'est un concert
un petit peu spectaculaire mais on aime
bien mettre en avant aussi
des artistes locaux on a eu les
scatophones Orchestra à plusieurs fois
les swingshateurs si on a eu un très
beau concert aussi avec Anthony fresh
voilà donc on a de la chance en Touraine
d'avoir une scène musicale
extraordinaire donc quand on peut les
mettre en avant l'ADN du Château
d'Artigny c'est aussi la musique
classique donc on a une belle saison
voilà qui se qui se prépare également
merci beaucoup
dans notre journal